514 here on a tuesday morning a tasty
tradition back in las vegas at the
convention center starting today it is
the international pizza expo the latest
and greatest creations to give us plenty
of calories and come straight out of the
oven um so delicious this morning we got
a sneak peek of danny o'malley joining
us here this morning this is before the
butcher that's the company that you're
here with and that essentially means
plant-based meat that is correct i
founded this company almost five years
ago and we make plant-based meats
well before before we get into making
this let's talk about what the pizza
expo is obviously pizza is such a
popular food yeah i'm i love it i could
eat it every day breakfast lunch and
dinner what does the pizza expo do for
folks like yourself to try and highlight
and sort of tout the next the next phase
in pizza business yeah well the great
thing about this expo is it's that
international expo so people come from
all over the world to this expo and
we're able to show our products to
buyers uh either uh consumers but mostly
operators of restaurants and
caterers and sometimes distributors as
well that can help us distribute our
product and get it to the people that
want to use it whether it's traditional
pizza or some of this plant-based food i
am plant-based so to me this is really
exciting i haven't tried before the
butcher but you know a lot of people who
are just getting into it my husband
being one of them he's like
oh wow that does taste good so for folks
at home who might go plant-based i don't
know
it's delicious right and it doesn't
taste too far off from the original no
no it's a twist on traditional how's
that and we've got uh plant-based meat
here uh which my company makes we also
have a plant-based cheese daiya cheese
and then a plant-based egg
just egg seems to go against the grain
it does but it's great i mean so many
people have allergies so this gives them
you know an alternative so let's get
started here you're putting together
what are you putting together right now
so i'm putting the egg in here i'm gonna
put a little salt and pepper okay
we are gonna make a breakfast pizza
right breakfast pizza all right so we're
gonna take uh we're gonna take this egg
and mix it up a little bit a little salt
and pepper i'm gonna put a little bit of
not what i called it this is plant-based
meat not what i called it before we
started right now yes you cannot say
fake meat
we have elevated
we've elevated the culinary experience
so we've got
diet cheese the plant-based meat we're
pouring it onto the uh the um the crust
right there look at that see the
consistency is like a real egg it is so
you wouldn't know so we're gonna we're
gonna pour that on there like this
and spread it around a little bit and
then get it in the crevices of course
yeah this is going to cook up just just
like egg would cook up inside your oven
yeah well let's uh we'll keep making
this right now we're going to catch up
with you in the next hour and see how
this progresses along here so you can
put inside danny o'malley from uh from
thank you very much for for making
breakfast for us oh you better yeah
good texture all right yeah we're going
to get a cherry and aid in here and have
some of this when it's time to eat but
meantime weather time